[Music]
on this friday night
assault type guns immediately banned
the feds take aim at 1500 types of
firearms you don't need an ar-15
to bring down a deer what it means for
owners the bank of canada's new governor
he has the the right qualifications the
man ottawa is putting
its money on to steer our economy out of
the covid19 crisis
from rescue to recovery the worst fears
of canada's military community
now confirmed and what's waiting in the
wings for airlines
if there's social distancing on the
plane i think that leads to higher fares
where the industry is headed after these
turbulent times
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin with sweeping new restrictions
on assault style weapons in this country
the federal government has now made it
illegal to buy sell
or use roughly 1500 different types of
guns
it comes after last week's massacre in
nova scotia one of the worst
mass killings in canadian history
30 years from now an entire generation
of canadians will remember
exactly where they were on sunday april
18
2020 they will remember how their sense
of safety
was shaken how their outlook on the
world
was forever changed they will remember
the day that they lost
some of their innocence this chapter in
our history
cannot be rewritten but what happens
next is up to us
we can stick to thoughts and prayers
alone
or we can unite as a country and put an
end to this
we can decide together that enough
is enough on the list of banned weapons
guns used in past mass shootings
including the ar-15
for people who already own these now
prohibited weapons
the government says there's a two-year
amnesty period and it's working on a
program
to buy back the guns michael couture
walks us through the details
and the reaction you don't need an ar-15
to bring down a deer one simple
statement providing a possible peek
behind the liberals decision
to ban what they call assault style
rifles in canada
try not to target hunters and other
lawful gun owners the government says
these types of guns
have no legitimate civilian purpose
these weapons were designed for one
purpose
and one purpose only to kill the largest
number of people
in the shortest amount of time 1500
makes and models are included in the ban
including the gun used in the 2014
moncton shooting and
the ones used by the men who killed 14
women at montreal's called politecnic
in 1989. for me it feels like half a
victory
not a complete one natalie provost
survived that attack despite
being hit by four bullets she's been
lobbying for stricter gun laws but even
she is disappointed by the announcement
there was supposed to be a complete ban
on [ __ ] style weapon now we see that
it's not totally complete
so what are gun owners supposed to do if
they have one that is now prohibited
there will be a grandfathering process
and a two-year amnesty period
while the government sorts out a
buy-back program canadians who purchase
these guns did so legally
and we did not want to create a
situation by prohibiting them all
moving forward of putting those people
in criminal
jeopardy buy back program or not gun
advocates say the entire
ban is just smoke and mirrors there's no
technical basis for it it's purely a
political move
it will have no effect on crime in
canada it will not make canadians any
safer
it is political the liberals campaigned
on gun control so the prime minister
believes he has the mandate to make this
move
but the latest numbers may not bear that
out a recent ipsos poll for global news
shows 52 percent of urban canadians
believe all guns should be made illegal
in this country
the results may have been different if
rural areas were also
surveyed no handguns aren't covered in
this ban
even though the latest stats show they
accounted for 57 percent of
firearm related homicides in 2018.
when asked about it trudeau said his
government plans to move forward on that
in the coming months robin michael
couture in ottawa thanks mike
the federal government has appointed a
new governor of the bank of canada
tiff macklin has a heavy burden
navigating canada through this economic
uncertainty caused by the pandemic
david aiken has more on macklin's
history and why he got the top job
i'm looking forward to building on the
fine standard that governor polos
his team and our predecessors have
provided
tiff macklin was always one of the
favorites to follow the retiring stephen
polos
macklem had been the number two man at
the bank to
former governor mark carney together
carney and macklem along with former
prime minister stephen harper and then
finance minister jim flaherty
helped steer canada through the 2008
financial crisis
governor designate macklem brings a deep
knowledge of the canadian economy
and financial markets he was one of
canada's leading economic stewards
during the 2008 financial crisis
expertise that will serve
canada well as we work to deal with the
covet 19 crisis
for now macklem's approach to the
current crisis will be to continue
steering the bank on the same course
set by polos the important message to
canadians
is that the bank of canada is here to
play its part
uh to to providing
uh essential liquidity to the financial
system so that the financial system can
play its role
keep credit flowing macklin will turn 60
next year
he was born in montreal he's fluently
bilingual and after spending
most of his career at the department of
finance and the bank of canada
he spent the last few years as the dean
of the business school at the university
of toronto
i certainly think he has the the right
qualifications for this
um he might not be that well known uh to
to your average canadian but
uh certainly his name is well known on
on bay street
i mean this leadership transition uh
comes as
canada is experiencing one of the
steepest declines in economic activity
on record
uh millions of canadians tens of
thousands of businesses are
relying on new federal measures for
short-term liquidity for eventual
recovery
macklem's first day as canada's 10th
central banker
will be june 3rd david aiken global news
ottawa search efforts have shifted to a
recovery mission in the mediterranean
sea where a canadian navy helicopter
crashed
five people on board that flight are
presumed dead
a sixth person sub-lieutenant abigail
cobra
is confirmed dead their cyclone
helicopter was returning to hmcs
fredericton
after a training exercise when it went
down in the ionian sea wednesday
as rosslard reports the canadian armed
forces say
it's found more remains but they have
not been identified
yet another day of grief in nova scotia
and another growing shrine
there's even more pain to come now that
the military confirms none of the six
occupants survived a canadian navy
helicopter crash
off the coast of greece we are certain
that if there were survivors
we would have found them within the past
48 hours
navy officials say they've found
additional remains which will not be
identified until they're brought back to
canada next week
they've also discovered more wreckage
from the cyclone that crashed into the
ocean about three kilometers from hmcs
fredericton
we have found additional debris
associated with the helicopter
including a side door and pieces of the
fuselage
as tributes continue military
instructors who knew
several of the fallen honor them with
words keen young professional officers
they accepted the risk of the life they
had chosen
they knew they were taking risks at sea
in the air and on the ground
they knew that and they accepted it and
they got on with the job an air force
flight safety team is leaving canada to
investigate the accident
the military says members will begin
their work as soon as they arrive in
italy
and travel to the crash scene the
cyclone fleet will also come under
scrutiny
in 2017 a software problem in the flight
control system
forced a cyclone to suddenly drop in
altitude during training
grounding the helicopters for nine weeks
i know they had to make a quick landing
at one point but it turned out to be
minor this retired navy commander who
studied the cyclones
says the choppers are popular with
pilots the reports i've been hearing
many of them from people who fly the the
cyclone are
the pilots love flying that aircraft
it's powerful
it's responsive the air force says it's
confident previous problems have been
resolved
the navy says hmcs fredericton will
leave the crash scene
and sail to italy the 200 plus crew
members will pause first
to hold a vigil paying tribute to their
fallen colleagues
ross lord global news halifax
nova scotia is also still grieving the
loss of 22 lives in a murder rampage
nearly two weeks ago
among those killed 49 year old lisa
mccully
a teacher and musician global news spoke
with her sister jenny kirstead who was
remembering her
as a natural leader someone who loved
nature and life
mccauley was also a devoted mother her
two children
were home with her on that saturday
night hiding in the basement
on the phone with 9-1-1 that dispatcher
was the kid's lifeline
for two long hours and they helped
them through and they are they are safe
and that is a blessing
kierstead is now hoping to meet with the
dispatcher on the other end of that call
that night
shifting to some more positive news here
at home after weeks of tight coven 19
restrictions
today people on prince edward island
found themselves with a bit more freedom
starting today islanders can now access
more non-urgent health care services
such as physiotherapy groups of up to
five people from different households
are also allowed to gather outside as
long as they practice
physical distancing ontario has yet to
ease its restrictions
but some relief is on the way premier
doug ford says
a select number of businesses will be
allowed to reopen
on monday folks our hard work
and perseverance our patience is paying
off
today is a glimmer of hope and
it couldn't come soon enough
some of the businesses allowed to open
monday include garden centers with
curbside pickup
as well as some car washes and auto
dealerships
but the businesses must abide by public
health rules including
physical distancing quebec says it plans
to ramp up testing as it begins to ease
restrictions
the province's chief medical health
officer says the goal is to conduct up
to 14
000 tests per day up from roughly six
thousand
quebec has been hardest hit by the virus
as of today it's recorded more than 27
000 cases and more than 2 000 people
have died
today alone quebec reported more than
1100 new cases across the country
more than 1800 new cases have been
recorded
the number of coven 19 cases is still
rising in many countries
but so is the number of recoveries and
today the world reached
a positive milestone according to johns
hopkins university more than a million
people have now recovered from covet 19.
in canada just over 55 000 people have
tested positive
of those roughly 22 000 have recovered
some more positive news the u.s food and
drug administration has approved the use
of the drug
rem de severe for emergency covenanting
treatment
researchers say preliminary tests show
the drug may help patients recover
faster from the disease new pressure on
an american presidential candidate
coming up joe biden responds to
allegations of sexual assault
plus the road to rebuilding fort
mcmurray after
another disaster
a glimmer of hope tonight for residents
in fort mcmurray alberta
a mandatory evacuation order has been
lifted in some areas
and some residents are getting a
firsthand look at their homes to assess
any flood damage dallas flex hog reports
it's a nightmare leon huffy has lived
twice
i just got saddled back in and now we're
running again
cupe lost his house in the 2016 wildfire
it was only rebuilt last year for it to
be destroyed again this week by flooding
like so many others in fort mcmurray
he's endured a lot and he's trying to
figure out how to rebuild
everything all over again just after we
all went through this fire and now to be
hit again like this
it's like a double blow about 13 000
people
have been forced from their homes
because of rising water
mandatory evacuation orders were lifted
for some downtown areas friday but to be
clear conditions are improving and we're
beginning to turn the corner from
response to recovery
some residents and business owners are
permitted to access their properties
but everyone is being warned about
potential property damage
and they may not be able to live in
their homes yet we do have evacuees
returning
now and i expect throughout the weekend
that will continue as for the full
length of
when we can expect everybody to be back
home i don't think that's been
determined
this week marks four years since a
wildfire ripped through fort mcmurray
this property restoration specialist
says helping rebuild after that natural
disaster
and then again now is a lot in a short
span of time
mentally it's exhausting i find that
trying to comprehend
what's going on right now is very
difficult
not knowing what's actually going to be
going on
we'll hopefully get in today and be able
to assess buildings see what's kind of
going on and see the actual damage that
happened
damage assessment teams have been
deployed in the community as a recovery
plan gets underway
essential businesses including key
government infrastructure
grocery stores gas stations and
pharmacies will be given priority
the return of residents in the downtown
core is happening a lot faster than
first anticipated after water levels
were seeded significantly
some areas that were submerged under
meters of water now only have
puddles in the street robin dallas flex
hog
in fort mcmurray alberta still ahead the
turbulent times facing airlines pushed
the brink by this pandemic
for those itching to get away air canada
predicts flights will resume
by christmas time speaking with the
canadian club of toronto the company's
vice president tim strauss
says he expects to see a significant
amount of flying domestically
and to most places around the world but
he warns their travelers to brace
for fewer flight options the airline
industry has been hit
hard by the economic impact of kova 19.
many airlines are facing huge losses
over a major drop in demand redmond
shannon takes a look at what air travel
could look like
in a post pandemic world going
nowhere almost two-thirds of all
commercial aircraft are currently
parked some airlines have had to
literally chop
wood to make enough wheel chocks the
covert 19 pandemic
is already pushing airlines in south
africa and australia to the brink
even profitable air canada and westjet
can only tolerate so much
in aviation cash reserves disappear
quickly
united airlines lost 2 billion u.s
dollars in the first quarter
it's raising funds by selling some
planes and then
leasing them back so the 2 billion loss
here
could easily become a 10 12 15 billion
dollar loss and that's just with one
airline
worldwide passenger demand is forecast
to have this year
with no end in sight for the government
bailouts
part of that problem is we don't know
what the other side looks
like is that two months three months
five months
even governments don't have a an
infinite ability to print money
many airlines can't even take advantage
of the low oil prices
they're usually locked in to rates
agreed to last year
obligated to pay for fuel they can't
even burn
the crisis could truly reshape the
industry
one that by its nature helps spread the
virus
it must now make sure it minimizes the
risk of any resurgence
[Music]
dubai-based emirates is introducing
thermal scanning and antibody tests for
passengers
with physical distancing on board too if
you start to
limit how many people they can put on a
plane that unravels the whole
fabric of how they have built a
financial
uh model but if there's social
distancing on the plane i think
that leads to higher fares these new
rules could make
discretionary air travel less than
enticing
at least until a vaccine arrives well i
want to wear a face mask
to fly from washington to san francisco
let alone to fly
from new york to missouri
any sort of recovery will be a tough
sell for airlines
renationalizing some famous flag
carriers as is happening
in italy may not be out of the question
redmond shannon global news
london to the us now where presumptive
democratic presidential nominee joe
biden is denying allegations he sexually
assaulted a former employee
in the early 90s i'm saying
unequivocally
it never never happened it's the first
time
biden has addressed the accusation by
former senate staffer tara reid
reid alleges he assaulted her in a
capitol hill hallway
biden is calling on the national
archives to release any records of
complaints
but insists there are none reed did not
report the alleged incident to police
until last month up next a day dedicated
to doctors and the battles they face
daily
in honor of may day ships around the
world sounded their horns to honor the
heroes of the high seas
vessels blasted their horns for at least
three minutes the event draws attention
to the people working around the clock
to keep global supply chains flowing
during the pandemic
and every day health professionals are
also working around the clock during the
pandemic
they're on the front lines and the last
line of defense in this fight against
the virus
tonight in honor of national physicians
day we're shining a spotlight on the
incredible work and sacrifices they make
every day here's mike troulay yes
in ray gentle's darkest moment battling
covet 19
he was in need of medical care and
something more
i was hyperventilating i was sweating
like a pig
i was just losing it within the
paramedic scheme and they calmed me down
a lot
it's that ability to relate to people in
crisis
that sets frontline healthcare workers
apart and if canadians didn't know that
before
all they need to do is open their
windows at 7 pm
and listen
[Applause]
this is vancouver paying tribute to
doctors and nurses and orderlies
and anyone else fighting for the raid
gentles of the world
it's a scene that's playing out every
day in cities across the country
and after the cheering subsides the
lights turn on
giant hearts to express gratitude so
these things are really helpful and they
really uplifting because there are times
where we're kind of just sitting there
in the hospital thinking you know when
is this going to end
and just knowing we have all that
support from our community
and around the world is just it's just
really heartwarming and it keeps us
going
no one could fault physicians for
fearing all this
they trained for years to learn how to
heal few expected this big a battle
against an invisible virus
yet there they are returning to the
front lines every day
putting themselves and their families at
risk so when kirk thompson of london's
can-am rv center got a call from a nurse
needing to
physically distance herself from her own
family
he didn't hesitate she said would you
have an rv that we could rent from you
and i said
you know i'm not charging you anything
for this uh you know you're doing so
much for us
in the community and you're you're doing
you know you're making all the
sacrifices this is a minor thing for me
to do
it's not minor at all and he's since
lent out another 20 units to doctors and
nurses and other frontline staff
who are working countless hours and
sacrificing more than we've ever asked
of them
never losing that inherent trait of
compassion that sets them apart
every patient that walks in as a patient
is a human being on that other side
and we can't forget that in this crisis
on national physicians day
what better way to pay tribute than to
let them work
mike drolite global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday i'm robin gill
tonight we leave you with some of the
artistic tributes to canadian healthcare
workers
thank you for watching and i hope to see
you back here again tomorrow good night
[Music]